hey leute und willkommen zu den hunger
games zwei hier auf meinem kanal ich
muss mal kurz wahrscheinlich noch was
erklären und zwar handle games
uralte was ist da passiert naja hunger
games ist einfach eine map wo hier ganz
viele leute drin da sich diese ganzen
kapseln und da werden wir dann nachher
hoch gelassen wir können die sich
hierhin könnt ihr hier hin laufen und
dann gibt es hier ein paar items und
danach können die mit den items quasi in
alle richtungen über diese map hier
laufen die mehrtätige hat nicht so gut
geht dass eines der hochhäuser hier sind
noch ein hohes haus und hier sind heute
überall so ein paar ruin wo man halt
rumlaufen kann und sich verstecken kann
und es ist halb dvp an also jeder gegen
jeden sprich einmal wenn man hier
draußen das muss man quasi in dieser
kompletten welt für sich alleine sorgen
und versuchen der letzte überlebende zu
bleiben
und ja da muss ich mal kurz was zu
erzählen und zwar hatten wir am anfang
hier den staat gemacht
und das war ganz lustig weil erst mal
hat dem staat gar nicht richtig
mitbekommen und dann waren alle schon
hier drin ich bin dann rein gelaufen
alle hatten schon irgendwie feuerzeuge
und so was alles und dann würde ich
meinem fahrzeug angezündet und war
direktor zusammen mit dem bass die kekse
auch schon tot ist also ihr seht jetzt
gerade mal die leute eingeblendet die da
auch noch mitmachen und sobald ich hier
der shuffle hält wie auch noch das
werden wir beide dann skypen und dann da
weiter aufnehmen und naja jedenfalls
weichelt dann direkt von anfang an todt
ich hoffe mal dass es nicht schlimm für
euch weil ich konnte das eigentlich
nicht so sehr viel für aber ich habe mir
da was anderes überlegt und zwar gibt es
hier auf dem server den command
spectator und dann zum beispiel spox
dann schauen wir mal einfach dem zukauf
will ich so alt was hat denn der schon
alles für sachen
woher hast du die ganzen sachen nein
sachen nein mit den sachen
alter das ist echt übel was der
schnellste kann ich jetzt noch so ne ich
bin ja mit creative ok stadt kiste alter
junge das ist also ich habe da gar nicht
alles ich hab nix gekriegt in den staat
kisten und das war dann auch eigentlich
so mehr oder weniger das problem
und wisst ihr was ich kann ja mal das
alles hier aufhält stellt sich auch
sogar ein bisschen mehr das war halt das
problem das ich dann am anfang fast gar
nichts bekommen haben und dann direkt
rot war aber ich habe mir gedacht dass
dieses komplette hunger games eh viel
geiler sein wird wenn wir anderen
zuschauen werden und dann quasi er war
der einzige welcher die kästen
ausgeräumt hat und dann wird das viel
lustiger denn wir allgemein wird zum
beispiel die letzten überlebenden sind
zum beispiel spark und 3play und die
beiden bekämpfen sich dann können wir
immer bei 3play mal zu schauen dann mal
bei iceberg zu schauen das ist halt ganz
lustig dann und na ja also wir werden
jetzt erst mit dem spark zu schauen das
ist gerade schon nacht oder wir können
ja auch mal eben
spectators llp ich glaubte auch ganz gut
dabei na ja sagt jetzt nicht so die
aller geld zusammen
jetzt schauen wir mal dem shuffle lp zu
der ist der denn hier
alter
ok wohl darum lästigen wo ganz weit oben
glaube ich
ok und wisst ihr was ich jetzt auch
gemacht habe ich habe mich auch ein
bisschen management gesetzt sage ich neu
und zwar kann ich dadurch jetzt von
anderen usern nicht gesehen werden das
heißt ich mache mit dem wie geht das
paket auch weil es mal so wir können
jetzt einfach mal selber ein bisschen
rum für mich zeigt euch mal ein wenig
die map was aber den daumen warum ist
ein diamant
das ist ja interessant das ist einfach
nur wegen junk fehlern
da unten ist und jemand
genau hier herunter da können wir
einfach investieren hier rumlaufen ein
bisschen gucken
und wie gesagt also mich sieht gerade
niemand weil ich dieses buch magic dann
habe oder wie das heißt so schaut meine
uhr und da sind diese glaswände das
heißt dass dieser kuppel hier darf man
nicht raus die map ist relativ groß sage
ich mal
hier oben haben die kiste da ist ein
apfel feiler ach da kann man sich noch
mehr teile machen okay
kann man hier dann irgendwie ja man muss
dann die quasi so hoch laufen hier gibt
es auch alle halten welche tücken dass
man dann ging der rheinfelder woanders
also die etwas wirklich ziemlich schnell
aufgebaut ich werde die wahrscheinlich
irgendwann später oder wir werden das
noch mal machen also da wäre ich
ziemlich stark für weil es schon ein
bisschen blöd dass ich direkt am anfang
getötet werde aber naja müssen die sich
dann müssen sich die anderen jetzt halt
schlagen euro schaut man haben wir
wieder eine kiste ja aber dann hat sich
und zwei pfeile jetzt auch irgendwo noch
christen die irgendwas kulisse inhalten
ihnen diesen diamanten oder so naja ich
erkläre ich mal kurz die regeln und zwar
was wir denn hier unten das ist ja auch
ganz interessant ist vielleicht eine
u-bahn-station also und das hat doch
gerade investieren ich weiß nicht warum
naja egal man darf halt keine blöcke
hier von dem zum beispiel abbauen oder
zerstören und man darf nur blöcke setzen
die in besten lagen und gesehen gehört
oliver 333 wurde von stuck felix getötet
also
wartet ich flieg mal kurz hierdurch mal
sehen ob wir hinten irgendwas haben
also was passiert wenn ich das drücke
ich weiß es nicht
und da werden auch drei oder auch schon
heute geführte tier und ein system also
ist alles echt ziemlich geil aufgebaut
freak immer einfach durch also man sieht
schon deutlich das war bisher einer der
besten des weil der körper sie der
einzige war der sich am anfang die
sachen genommen hat und das war doch
nicht mein fehler dass sie am anfang
quasi den staat gar nicht nichts
mitbekommen habe das könnt ihr euch auch
bei den anderen dann gucken
weil es bei mir da einfach total gelegt
hat ich weiß nicht warum herr schaut man
ja mit einer kiste
mann und das hat jetzt mal noch das ist
einfach weil wir so viele plugins darauf
gottenheim toll das ist einfach weil da
so viele plugins drauf sind und ich
warte jetzt einfach mal muss der traum
vom von wahrscheinlich dem spark auch
geduldet wird weil es war der einzige
ist der richtig geile sachen hat wir
können eben dem westen noch alles drin
glaubt die trotz noch drin
ach ja niemandem respekt
tdd lte soll doch na ja da bin ich schon
mal gold schwert
und das hat dann noch so ein letztlich
war der kann sich eine farm machen toll
dass setzen hat auch ein bisschen blöd
wegen diesen lecks oder so warten wir
können jetzt mal ein paar anderen zu
schauen
also den habe ich die übelste gestartet
werden nur was zu essen und wenn nicht
gut der hat jetzt in eisen aber der
braucht zwei eisen und sich ein schwer
zu machen und er baut dann braucht ihr
noch holz und so was alles
naja schauen wir uns das mal weiter
annähert toll dna jetzt hat er sich
eigentlich aber ich glaube der schreibt
hat einfach was in der zeit können wir
einfach mal dem
label
gamer zu sehen wo ist er denn die hat
der spark ist eigentlich somit der
einzige der sich die ganzen sachen
sofort geklappt hat weil der auch glaube
ich somit der einzige war ja vorher
schon mal die map gespielt hat also sich
die forscher bedeutet hat
das
bringt darunter springen darunter los
sterbe
ok
der ist gerade auch im hochhaus und ich
weiß nicht ob es irgendwo noch eine
signale kiste gibt wurde quasi in
diamant schwert und bogen und so was
alles drin ist womit man die anderen
alle sprechen kann
naja wir schauen mal wieder dem shuffle
lp zu
ihr habt quasi bei mir sondern
konversation standpunkt wo wir allen
leuten einfach mal zu schauen und wo ist
er denn jack umbau dich auf
ich bin
letzte nacht micro es macht auch mit so
und das ist gerade echt billig aspekt
modus weil sich hier erst mal alles
aufbauen muss
ich gebe einfach wieder aus diesem
aspekt tate modus raus
der soll schweigen schon hier ist
so ich versuche einfach irgendwo
hinzufliegen wo so ein paar leute sind
da hinten ist glaube ich jemand wollen
die das sind leute die hier wer ist das
denn das is back oder wie alter alter
hat der geile sachen der wird das 100
prozentig gewinnen
echt krass
also schaut euch das an der hat eine
gold wurde der sondern der hat quasi die
komplette rüstung und wenn wir uns das
mal bei dem dann ansehen
mag auf phoenix
alter der hat echt ein paar geile sachen
ich hoffe er hat drei schwere werten
bogen der hat etwas zu essen wird noch
ein goldener apfel und das ist echt
krass also wenn der nicht gewinnt dann
wäre hier glaube ich echt irgendwas
falsch oder so
so also ich glaube das leben noch fünf
oder vier leute und gibt man kommt mal
ein bisschen trainers markus unter den
er wird jetzt eigentlich direkt
verrecken
und da sind mit den freitag sind derzeit
ja ok ok den ach so gut wie tot okay ich
bin dann auch war trotzdem musste ich
aber nach wie vor besteht dass man erst
mal sauber den
moslems park of phoenix
hat federn weg ist und er hat sein
inventar schon voll
krass dass
wäre es wenn er sein seien dinge mit
schon voller sein inventar
alter schwede
das wäre echt krass wenn dann richtig
wartet manchmal kurz hier was machen so
nein nicht
per telefon von skype gehört so wir
schauen wir einfach weiter den dingen
steht zu dem spark er steht da oben dran
fest weil sie nicht auf jeden fall spark
ich setze einfach mal so hunderttausend
euro auf stark weil der das nicht
gewinnt dann
läuft daher glaube ich echt irgendwas
schief
weil ich hoffe ich dass wir alle drei
verschiedene schwerter aber wir werden
jetzt erst mal diese blöden vom
ok auf einmal werde ich rausgeschmissen
paket schaffe
so wusste er denn das heißt ein hochhaus
oder nehme ich doch dass im erdgeschoss
und darum einen charakter ist ein start
okay jetzt sind es noch fünf lebende
header dafür auch schon
naja
ok dena ist tot das kann ich sagen
network minecraft also basti ist tot wer
es dann sonst noch so gestorben ich
glaube dreiecks gestorben
minecraft pocket noch nie dabei
ich bin tot
und ich glaube die einzigen die noch
leben sind debitor spark table tennis
gamer und schaffe also das sind quasi
die vier überlebenden und ich hätte am
liebsten jetzt aber hier war damit noch
dabei wie schon gesagt dabei den
kompletten start sind nicht verpennt
naja was soll man denn da sind zwar
offen okay
tja tom was machst du besser auch nicht
ich will einfach mal hoch geht ja genau
ich
würde eigentlich noch einen höher gehen
wo er packt festmeter dich
die kann man den us bank
geht das so
noch mal ganz kurz fließen
also gut also alle sind eigentlich noch
am aufnehmen außer so ein oliver
blablabla ich weiß gar nicht wer das ist
okay
messe
keine sorge habe nicht gezielt hat sieht
man in aufnahme ok message last week's
ja aber ist schon irgendwie
ja okay es hat geklappt also tom weil es
glaube ich auch nicht so richtig was er
da soll und ich denke tom wird auch
hundertprozentig nicht gewinnen weil er
hat drei fleisch und dann drei wäre also
der kann sich damit wirklich nichts
kaufen
da hilft es hier drüber einfach ja okay
das ist ein bisschen langweilig wir
schauen wir einfach dem
bald schon ist trotzdem
okay wir schauen wir einfach dem spark
noch ein bisschen zu
weil ich denke eigentlich dass der so
mit ja
dann wird das nochmal prozentig gewinnen
weil schaut etwas inventaren der war
quasi der einzige der sich da am anfang
so ein paar sachen raus genommen hat
war der einzige der sich sachen
sache
also man könnte quasi schon sagen wenn
ihr das irgendwann spielt und ihr da da
in seiner
ja in seinem geld seit
christlich-soziale drohen ja toll
dann ist das schon ganz witzig weil
das hatte ich überhaupt sagen also wenn
ihr das nicht spielt geht sofort auf die
kisten
geht sofort auf die kisten das ist echt
so mit das wichtigste ist dass das buck
der alle schon rausgeholt sich diese
verzauberten schwerter pfeile bogen
passions essen alles möglich
herausgeholt und dann
naja wenn wenn wenn man es nicht macht
hat man dann halt verpackt so wie ich
so was haben wir da
oben sind dann wartet man wird schauen
wir einfach mal spectator von dann
fliegen waren einfach zu stark
der müsste doch da irgendwo sein glaube
ich
also da war er auf jeden fall hin
ich weiß aber nicht genau wo ein kommt
man hier noch mit müsste
nicht nur eine ganz kurze sich hier nase
pudern okay hier sicherster eingebracht
das schweinefleisch und einen pfeil und
chemikerin ja man
muss auch mal sein
was hat er geschrieben wie wispert man
nicht nehmen nicht mehr auf